إذا كان الفن قناة دراسة صغيرة منه
أثير من قبل نظام روبن
محاطًا بالعلم بهذه الطريقة
تقنية
البونوبوس اللوحة boskoopse الدائري
أقوم بإعادة تعيين الحقول المصغرة
العلجوم وفكرة لعبة التكنولوجيا في
رقائق البرمجيات و eadys
وكانت عائلتي وسيلة لصنع بلدي
العالم ليه وحشية ليه قاسية وأكثر انفتاحا
وأكثر تفاعلية
هي أنت أو أصبحت التكنولوجيا أكثر
في meurs هذا شيء ممكن ثانيًا
طبقة
[تصفيق]
فكرتك تحديات عالمية مثل
بلوزة ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر من co2 ومحاولة
لتحويله أصبح ممتعًا
أمل وحدة كاملة ومثل جميلة
حل في الداخل
نعم سأبقى على ميثاق التبديل الخاص بها
لذلك ارتديها في الضيق الطويل
تحويل الأبراج الخالية من الدخان إلى جيوب
من الناحية السياسية ، هناك جزء مهم من الهواء النظيف
جزء كبير من علم الأحياء في إلين
المستوى zoë يبني مساعدتها على الموت
رأى ksav de pan بريد الرياح كما لو كان
إدارة الحلاق
من يجب أن أخلق كيف أتعامل معك
تقنية
التفكير الإبداعي جاهز في العشاء
أو على دبوس kaikoura عدسة
هذا ماذا عن هوية الفن لدينا
تعمل بالشكل الذي تريده فماذا عن العقل
ودموعه أصل إلى هناك ضوء حقيقي
ليست تلك الطبقة من الضوء و
رطوبة
muchos الحصول على هاي دي ليفينج وياقوت أون
كان علي أن أستثمر في عملك خطوة بخطوة
لقد توقفوا عن التفكير في الغزلان الخاص بي
المستقبل باس لدي كثافة عالية
وتحرر لها عدسة
قمت بوضع الزاوية الصحيحة لها نفس الشيء
الخدمة المسطحة والكون الخاص بك
الكمبيوتر okapi الذي أفعله
يخلق
حركات آسف زي التي تولد الآن
بحاجة لي تلك البهجة
في البداية تأكد من أن
ترددات السقوط في بعضها البعض
مثل الحصول على ذروة طويلة من حوله و
ثم الآن الوسطاء لديهم تلك الرائحة
للتأكد من أنه عندما تكون الأضواء
أنك في منتصف تلك الفرصة
الضوء المرئي ليس هو عليه
شيء يصبح مرئيًا
وكم هي في أمستردام في باريس
الى الارض
الأمم المتحدة في نيويورك 60.000 شخص
عرض أب في أمستردام
والآن سمعت أنني كنت نائمة أتحدث عن الوجود
بتات قاتمة جدا تهتم بالتجربة
الإنتفاض في المعاينة الأيرلندية
ولكن هذا سحر جميل مرة أخرى
الواقع الافتراضي والواقع العقلي
ما في نفس الوقت القرف الاتصال الحقيقي
يمكنك أن تسقطها يمكنك تجربتها
معا تكنولوجيا القفز دي كبار السن
شاشة الكمبيوتر وإنشاء ملف هو
تجربة جماعية
الحيوانات الأليفة أنه يغرقها لاعب كرة القدم أو النطر